.
THE QUESTION IS, WILL YOU.
THAT IS THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW IS KENTUCKY
SENATOR RAND PAUL.
I'M GOING TO GET TO THE REST OF
MY ANKLE IN JUST A MOMENT, BUT
NEED TO GET YOUR REACTION TO
THIS REPORTING LATE TODAY FROM
THE NEW YORK TIMES THE DRONE
STRIKE THAT WE WERE TOLD TOOK
OUT AN ISIS FACILITATOR IN
AFGHANISTAN ACTUALLY KILLED A
U.S. AFFILIATED AID WORKER IN
NINE OTHERS INCLUDING MUCH OF
HIS FAMILY IN SEVEN CHILDREN.
THE CAR THEY TOLD US WAS FILLED
WITH EXPLOSIVES, EXPLOSIVES
THAT'S BECAUSE SECONDARY
EXPLOSIONS, IT WAS ACTUALLY
FILLED WITH WATER JUGS ACCORDIN
TO THE NEW YORK TIMES
INVESTIGATION.
FOX HAS NOT INDEPENDENTLY
CONFIRMED THAT, BUT THERE WERE
NUMEROUS EYEWITNESSES ON-SITE O
SITE THAT NIGHT THAT DID.
SENATOR, YOUR REACTION.
>> IF IT'S TRUE, IT'S ANOTHER
SAD INSTANCE OF THE MOST
INCOMPETENT WITHDRAWAL WE'VE
EVER SEEN IN OUR HISTORY, BUT
YES, WE WILL AWAIT FOR THE FACT
AS THEY COME FORWARD, BUT I'M
NOT SURPRISED THAT WE SAW A
BOMBING DONE TO SHOW WHERE NOT
AS BACKLESS AS IT LOOKS LIKE WE
WERE AND THE WITHDRAWAL, AND AN
THE END IF THEY MADE A MISTAKE
IN IT, THAT WILL BE ONE MORE
DISASTROUS FACT AFTER ANOTHER.
I HOPE IT'S NOT TRUE, IF IT IS
TRUE, THAT IS DEVASTATING.
>> MUCH EASIER ALWAYS TO TELL
THE TRUTH INITIALLY, BUT I THIN
IT'S WORTH IT FOR AMERICANS TO
LISTEN BACK TO THE PENTAGON
INITIAL COMMENTS ABOUT WHAT WEN
DOWN, THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE
PENTAGON, ALL OF IT.
THIS WAS JUST TWO WEEKS BACK.
>> THE SELF-DEFENSE STRIKE
SUCCESSFULLY HIT THE TARGET NEA
KABUL AIRPORT.
SIGNIFICANT SECONDARY EXPLOSION
FROM THE TARGETED VEHICLE
INDICATED THE PRESENCE OF A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF EXPLOSIVE
MATERIAL.
>> I WILL NOTE THAT AND THE
STATEMENT THEY PUT OUT YESTERDA
LAST NIGHT THEY SHOULD SAY, WHA
THEY NOTED IS THAT THERE WAS
ALSO THE EXCLUSION THERE WERE
EXPLOSIVES IN THAT THEY COULD
HAVE LED TO ADDITIONAL DAMAGE.
>> THESE ARE THE SAME I GUESS
INTEL REPORTS BEING FED TO THES
WHITE HOUSE STAFFERS AND THE
PENTAGON THAT ARE ALSO FEEDING
INFORMATION ABOUT A POTENTIAL
DOMESTIC TERROR THREAT NEXT WEE
AT A RALLY THAT NO ONE HAS EVER
HEARD OF.
I DON'T TRUST ANY OF THESE
PEOPLE AT THIS POINT WHICH IS
TERRIFYING ON THE 20TH
ANNIVERSARY OF 9/11.
>> THE ONE THING WE DID KNOW AN
HAVE EYES ON WERE ALL OF THE
HELICOPTERS WE LEFT, ALL THE
PLANES, THE HUMVEES, THE ARMORE
PERSONNEL, THERE WERE A LOT OF
THEM THEY COULD'VE BLOOMED BLOW
UP ON THE WAY OUT WHEN WE KNEW
THE TALIBAN WAS GOING TO TAKE
OVER, THE EQUIPMENT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN DESTROYED ON THE WAY OUT
INSTEAD, AN ISOLATED ATTACK
SOMEWHERE WHICH MAY OR MAY NOT
HAVE KILLED ITS INTENDED TARGET
THIS HAS BEEN A LONG-STANDING
PROBLEM WITH SOME OF THE DRONE
ATTACKS, IT MAY EVEN SOMETIMES
GET THEIR TARGET, BUT THEY GET
TEN OR 15 INNOCENT PEOPLE AND
THE SAME NEIGHBORHOOD AS THE
TARGET AND IT CREATES ANTIPATHY
THAT REALLY MAY AND THE NBA
WORSE THAN THE INITIAL STRIKE.
>> IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE THE NEW
YORK TIMES REPORTING WEBSITES
POSITIVE TO DRONE ATTACK WHICH
IMPART HIT ITS END INTENDED
TARGET I DON'T THINK IT HIT ANY
OF ITS INTENDED TARGET.
I WANT TO GET BIKE MY ANGLE
BECAUSE AGAIN, ON THE EVE OF 9/
11, THE DISGRACED FORMER FBI
OFFICIAL ANDREW CAPE, HE IS
FOCUSED ON A DIFFERENT KIND OF
TERROR.
>> THE WORK OF COUNTERING
TERRORISM NEVER STOPPED.
THE UPCOMING RALLY ON THE 18TH
OR THAT PARTICULAR ANNIVERSARY
OF SIGNIFICANT ANNIVERSARY IS
UPON US LIKE THE ANNIVERSARY OF
9/11.
ANY EVENTS THAT COULD CAUSE
EXTREMISTS WHO WANT TO MARK
THOSE EVENTS WITH ACTS OF
VIOLENCE, FOCUS ON THOSE.
>> SOME RALLIES, AT LEAST UNDER
THE CONSERVATIVES I KNOW HAVE
EVER HEARD OF.
>> I THINK MOST OF WHAT THEY'VE
DONE IS TO CONSTRUCT AN ENEMY
THAT NEEDS TO BE SO IMPORTANT
THAT WE NEED A FENCE AROUND THE
CAPITAL.
AND I THINK THAT'S TOO REDIRECT
OUR VIEW AWAY FROM PORTLAND,
SEATTLE, CHICAGO, EVEN IN
LOUISVILLE, KENTUCKY, WE HAVE
MORE DESK PER CAPITA THAN
CHICAGO SO THEY ARE TAKING THIS
AWAY FROM THE GREAT PROBLEMS
THAT WE HAVE ACROSS THIS COUNTR
IN TRIED TO REDIRECT IT TOWARD
SOMETHING THAT WAS OBVIOUSLY A
MISTAKE TO TRY T